this is one of the biggest wholesale
fruit and vegetable markets in new delhi
thousands of street vendors come here
every morning to stock up on produce
from traders most of the bulk goods
arrive in trucks from neighboring
this truck here it comes from sambal in
uttar pradesh it used to cost 50 cents
for a sack of potatoes two weeks ago and
now it costs 60. the price of petrol and
diesel have gone up so this increases
too
those increases are being passed on to
shoppers such as salmati devi who has to
feed her four children on her earnings
of four dollars a day
we're buying less when prices are going
up we buy less and eat less people will
spend according to what they earn some
people have jobs some don't everyone is
helpless
almost daily fuel price rises over the
past two weeks have led to protests by
opposition parties in many indian cities
oil companies began raising prices after
a four-month pause while prime minister
narendra modi's buddhist party was
campaigning in recent state elections
india's petrol and gas minister says
many other countries are suffering much
higher rises and blames the war in
ukraine for disrupting oil imports
but the government raised fuel prices 63
times in the first half of last year
when there was no war india was also
among just a few countries that
increased fuel costs in the past two
years when crude prices were crashing
because of the pandemic
experts say years of rising living costs
are hurting the economy by driving down
consumption of non-essential goods
we are now in a situation where the
decline in consumption has now become
more and more entrenched in the economy
and so the only way to get out of that
is to some
external stimuli to kick-start the
economy but it is also hurting the
inflation as well as the
downside in the economy is also hurting
the ability of the government to
generate more revenues
in a country where the average daily
wage is the equivalent of five dollars a
day economists agree with consumers and
opposition parties that the government
must find an alternative to painful
price rises elizabeth piranha al jazeera
new delhi